they say that the d minor is the most
depressed chord the darkest chord really
of all the chords yeah because today
on the quarter cast we're gonna be doing
something a little different we're gonna
be talking about
the google graveyard it's actually
graveyard by google it's its own product
okay if you could guess how many
products
do you think google has killed over time
is it like thirty five five hundred
like one scale that's the thing like a
product
has been like adopted by a million
people
and like heavily marketed and like is
something that they have
rolled out with the intention of people
using it it's got branding behind it
it's got a finished
sort of execution behind it um yeah
maybe some patents i have no idea how
many patents google holds but
yeah they sat down at google they were
paid by
google or one of its subsidiaries and
those people
said hey this should be a product
i would guess and they and they made it
i'm gonna guess like 25.
really yeah i wow
interesting i don't know how many
products have died
but i have a feeling it's in the
hundreds well here's the thing in terms
of like big products that we recognize
i'm gonna say like 25.
i'm sure there's like yeah from a
corporate standpoint i bet you there's
like thousands
hold on uh-oh
hmm all right well in the meantime
wren this song's for you is it
[Music]
but i can help
falling in love with
you i'm glad you targeted this
specifically at me jake
yeah you're welcome i thought you would
enjoy it the most
i was enthralled okay good
but despite the distraction of a tech
problem going on apparently
um no solution yet
yeah you just had to tap it that was
that was the thing
i'm just going to tap everything method
just like hey
[Music]
no we don't cut anymore guys what you
just saw is a real moment that's how
sometimes technology works
um sometimes it janks out on you but all
it needs is a little tap sometimes you
just gotta
you know encourage dobie to to get out
of there
you gotta shush him out mm-hmm
we're talking about google products
we're talking about how many they've
killed
over time jordan what say you how many
google products do you think
that google has killed over time
i'm going to say six hundred and
fourteen
eighteen okay i know a thousand
i'm going to say a lot of people fail
with their business plan that's like
that that's more days if you release a
product a day that is
way more days than the company has
existed
yeah if the company has existed for 25
years
that's like approximately two products a
day
every single day but there's some really
people out there that are making
some crazy businesses and they're
failing
dude what about when the products start
making their own products that's when
you can start seeing those numbers
apple making products all right well i'm
actually
curious uh so before you give that
answer
i'm wondering if maybe we should give an
example of what we think is the most
give uh all four of us we should give
one example of a product that we know of
from google
that has failed i'll start with the
easiest one
google plus oh i didn't think you were
going to say that i thought you were
going to say something else
remember google was like hey we should
have a social media platform too
google plus remember when they mandated
that you couldn't have a youtube account
unless you had a google plus account
there was like a few years there where
you couldn't make a youtube account you
could only make a google plus account
yeah is it too early in this podcast to
go on a quick rant
uh-oh no it's never too early it's never
too early in the corridor cats to go on
a rant what the heck is like
multi-billion dollar companies just
making copies of other things that
already exist to try to do it better
stop that stop crushing the people that
are doing cool innovative things go out
there and make your own new idea
stop just duplicating what somebody else
did crushing the competition and then
crap in the bed and killing the thing
that you made shortly afterwards thereby
killing both versions
stop it if you have billions of dollars
go do something new that hasn't been
done yet rather than doing something
else that someone else already did just
because you want to steal their users
okay i'm done
since the beginning of time is there
anything specific you're referring to
here i was actually scrolling through
this list of things google killed and
just like
thing after thing after thing is google
trying to launch something to be a
competitor with someone something that's
already there
it's not getting adopted then google's
going ah and killing it like there's
like a bunch of like you know
next door like thing for neighbors you
know like where you can like it's a
social media for neighbors
they have like five versions of that
it's like clearly they're trying to eat
some of next door's lunch and get into
that space they can do stuff
and of course every single one of them
is dead like google killed each one
but like it goes on from there with like
various like other cool features or apps
or things that like
or somebody else is already doing it and
has an audience and google trying to
replicate it which is
very similar to the model of microsoft
in the year from the year 2000 to 2010.
microsoft was doing the exact same thing
with their zooms
and their windows phones and all that
kind of stuff
the xbox was like the first of that big
step you know oh yeah yeah fair play
so it's like stop just spending money to
do what
somebody else is already doing and like
why don't you try to fix some problems
or things that need fixing rather than
just doubling up on something that
somebody else is already putting the
time and money on it
all right this is a video we take
someone whose idea got stolen and we
revive it
that's a video right now wait here's an
idea here's an idea
we take some of corridor digital's work
and then we post it on tick tock
oh you mean wren's render that's just
going crazy all
over the place have you heard about any
of that jake the
my ticket yeah i last i heard it had 80
million views on tickets it's it's
probably going to cross 100 million
before the end of the day
isn't the gangnam style of tick tock i
mean i don't know i i i'm talking with
people and they're like oh yeah no that
kind of happens
like not at the same time
like this sort of thing only happens on
the entire platform once a week
nice so you should be the first of the
week
that's awesome i mean i mean maybe again
i know so little about tick tock again
i put this video up of the satisfying
render
on a whim i just threw it up on tick
tock and just cause
whatever fine sure sure i had friends
who were heckling me to do it and i was
like fine
um not expecting anything in return and
now over the course of the last three
days i have gained
550 000 followers on tiktok which is
more than
all of my other followings combined
something that i just did on a whim why
not sure
we kind of need to do something with
that i feel like it's mandatory at this
point
people don't even believe it's him yeah
if you're like why don't you credit the
original case
yeah it's so funny it's like i feel
flattered
because it's like at least they're
literally the guys
hey hey come on uh show some respect to
court don't steal their work and it's
like obviously they just don't know that
it's me who uploaded the video
obviously i mean it's like our tick tock
too people are like our tick tock has
gotten taken down like five times
yeah so i'm yeah no it's it's
it that's a little bit more confusing
and frustrating
um do you think people are analyzing
that account
no sorry apparently it is a lot of just
human error anytime like a video gets
taken down or whatnot you can fight back
and usually get it put back up
i have a friend who works at a tick tock
influencer
management company i think and she's
currently helping us
get stuff reinstated so she helped us
get the quarter account reinstated over
the weekend
uh hopefully will get us verified so
that this doesn't happen again
well you know that's very nice still
never put up the aaron versus the
colossal titan because they labeled it
as
nudity i'm like no one looks at attack
on titan and like thinks
oh this is hot but it's definitely it's
like
it's it's definitely kind of playing on
the idea that these are naked people but
the fact that they're not kind of just
goes over their heads that technology
yeah
well that's got to be all algorithm
stuff well no that's what i'm saying i
think
someone tripped it and you can fight
back but it's someone intentionally
doing it
but it might be algorithm i mean for
something like the attack on titan
nudity thing that seems a little bit
more algorithmic yeah
well cause we we uploaded three attack
on titans and i feel like
there has to be multiple submissions of
someone being like no this is nudity
this is nudity this is i think it's like
after a certain amount they go ahead and
take
it down and then a human analyzes it
and they're like yeah we reviewed it and
we decided it's nudity right i think
that that's what happens
i have so many degrees and complications
with tick tock
in general yeah i don't even know where
to begin
yeah right but well let's let's not and
let's stick to
the topic at hand
guys we've got a very special sponsor
today
it's story box once again that's story
blocks
so let me tell you all about them kid
storyblocks
is your one-stop shop for
all of your stock asset needs
they've got high quality 4kb
roll audio images music after effects
motion graphics templates and more
constantly updating their library
which is great if you need to put
something
in a video and you don't want to get
that
b-roll on your own they have an
unlimited
all access plan you can
use it however you want wherever you
want whenever you want it's royalty free
it's another creative tool in our
creative toolkit and
that's why we like it so if you want to
join me
head on over to
[Music]
storyblocks.comcast
that's storyblocks.com
we'll see you over there
[Music]
now back to the episode okay wait wait
wait i'm announcing google wave it's my
thing
why don't you buy tick tock and then
kill it oh they're doing
youtube shorts they're already doing
what they just explained they're already
launching their own version called
youtube shorts such as them just trying
to do what tic tac has already done
successfully and they're not gonna do it
as well they'll kill it in about two
years
or they won't and it's going to cheapen
the platform in general turning it into
a weird half tick tock half youtube
sorry
uh google wave is my product that i
loved and they killed it when i was in
the process of using it so
yeah if you've come to the place for
salty eco tech
you found it google wave was uh the
precursor to google docs it's basically
it combined
uh gmail discord and google docs into
one kind of cohesive platform
basically imagine a real time like forum
or like reddit thread where you as
people are writing you can see the
writing happening just like on google
docs like it's real-time writing
and you can do like comment threads
within themselves i have like one long
email chain basically where people are
leaving posts up
but basically just like a hyper dynamic
and living communication document
so like if you were say like we're using
it for productions we'd be like you know
like okay locations and we have like a
topic
location scouts at the top people like
you know here's what we're doing
locations we need so maybe somebody
makes a reply underneath that with
questions
maybe somebody answers those questions
underneath and then you keep going in
and you keep
adjusting those comments there as you
update with the things that you're
finding so it's like
you're updating cells in and of
themselves with new information but
you're also creating like a
message thread almost like an email
thread kind of thing going on but it's
also living within like topics as if it
was on a forum
it's basically just google going like
you know what's the way we can have
people communicate with each other
is the precursor like the slack you know
the slacks in the world and slack
honestly at this stage is just discord
with the corporate friendly skin
um so yeah it was really nice
and we were like legitimately using it
actively using it for like planning our
videos and doing like productions and
stuff like that
and google's like oh we're done
that was that so google wave later known
as apache wave
is a discounted software framework for
real time collaborating
collaborative editing online
[Music]
wow did you use it when it was apache
wave niko or
no only when
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know if they bought it from
yeah developers apache software
yeah they probably i wonder if they
bought apache because they like the
real-time text
stuff and then we want to implement that
in other things usually i think that's
what happens a lot of the time with big
like corporate buyouts is like
they don't want the product they just
want some of the the infrastructure
behind the product and potentially
patents like maybe
like the real time typing because it's
really cool in google docs and
somebody's writing and you can see
literally letter by letter
they're writing appearing yeah
it is not it was not bought by google oh
really
yeah it's a it's currently a small cap
um
c organization actually they spun it off
into a separate company
no it was always a separate company it's
an american non-profit corporation
then what's google what's the number of
they must have google bot
i think google bought it from them here
let's find out let's find out more guys
jake we're live we can't we can't be
sitting here just googling yeah this is
the first
podcast it's a podcast jordan do you
have any companies that
are sorry any products from google that
you might remember from back in the day
um back in the day i mean we can look at
that list
did you share that list some more jake
yeah it's on this oh there's a list
you can't think of any products like
google killed that google has
killed like google i'll go or i'll go in
the meantime
uh or google glass guys oh yeah google
glass
yeah i mean come on the tried and true
classic everyone thought it was going to
be the new new
everyone i mean did did people really
think that was going to be like the new
new thing
somebody did some people thought that
was going to be the thing
and then yeah and then i remember
brandon got a pair
it wasn't brandon it was one of his
employees okay so yes because that was
the one i tried was
was the one over there yeah it was the
case and immediately
you realized it was not going to be
but here's the thing it's like i i still
actually believe google
glass was just ahead of his time you
know it's like we're starting to see
some of the functionality that they were
dreaming up
coming to fruition today with like the
google sorry the snap spectacles
that they got and i imagine in another
10 years
you know see-through displays that are
built in the glasses
are just going to be fairly regular
perhaps still expensive and not
common but you know they won't be
rare i think the biggest realization
that i had when
donning both the google glass and the
hololens
was that the tech is super cool but if
you don't have any software
worth running then the tech is
immediately useless and google class was
kind of that thing was like
google glasses theory is really cool
like having a heads-up display that
tells you cool things happening in your
life and you suddenly realize that like
oh interfacing with it is really hard
and it really can't do very much
and it really just tells me the time and
the weather i don't really want to wear
something for that
you know it'd be cool to like analyze
what i'm looking at and like
or you know like like an example people
give like oh you're a tourist you're in
france you're looking at the eiffel
tower you hold up your phone and it
highlights different things and tells
you about them
that would be rad someone needs to go
make the software you know it's like
it's not a hardware thing it's a
software thing
like the hardware is almost trivial it's
it's putting all the the work into the
software that's like hard or like
another great example is you know how
great would it be if when you buy your
furniture from ikea
instead of having a paper manual you
whip out your phone and you point it at
the things and it just shows you
here's the box here's what that screw
goes here and it draws lines and it you
know
literally like paints it in front of you
as you're pointing it at the objects
that would be good nico they give you a
piece of paper that's a lot cheaper that
you can just
exactly it's the software that matters
they're the worst
yeah it's the same thing with vr
headsets right now like the quest 2 is
an amazing headset but if you don't have
good games worth running on it like
who cares if you have a great vr headset
you need to have cool software
i mean i think that's a big reason why
iphone started exploding after the app
store was released you know it was like
once you actually have this open api for
everyone to develop for
and and you can consume different types
of programs on it
it explodes it's the main isn't that the
main reason why uh no it's a slightly
different reason i was thinking why
microsoft
started exploding back in the 80s and
90s and just completely overtook apple
but that was because
microsoft was more of a an operating
system
company they got in all the all the pcs
they did they didn't limit dos and
windows to just one
hardware brand which is what apple was
doing yeah hey uh
do you guys think apple is justified
taking 30 of everything going through
the app store and also justified
and not letting you install any other
software unless it goes to the app store
i mean those are two questions first off
i'm conflicted about that i i don't
think i don't think they should
but if you're asking me like can they
you know no i didn't ask obviously
obviously they can and
there's nothing i can do anything wrong
i could kick out that window i could
break that line but no
should i i'm saying i'm not i'm saying
it's not illegal
obviously well yeah but should they who
nobody cares the answer
is to can they we all care what the
answer is to should they well okay i
think it's it's kind of complicated
because
i think we've actually talked about this
recently about the whole epic apple
thing yeah but like
touched on it 30
is already pretty steep but you know
what fine it's
it's whole platform fine yeah it's a
little bit monopolistic because they've
got a
you know billions of devices out there
and they can only use this one store
you think basing their cut on percentage
which is an arbitrary number versus an
actual cost is kind of so that's where
i'm getting it's like
if we're talking like just straight up
sales through the app store
you know what fine you want to keep it
that simple fine but i think there
should be an asterisk there like any
sort of follow-up
like i don't know i guess then everyone
would just do the asterisk version of it
like
uh if if they perhaps didn't take as big
of a share
for for what do you call like the the
things you pay for inside of the the
apps the in-game purchases or whatever
which is what app
or sorry which is what epic was trying
to do it's like hey you can get the in
internal game money stuff if you just
buy it through your webs
our website it'll still apply to your
account but you don't pay apple as much
then everyone just do that i guess i
don't know
yeah it's um there's definitely a
monopoly
concern there because you know it's
basically
android and them and android is everyone
else
and them and so i think given like their
market share
you know there's definitely concern
about monopolizing
which you know has a greater impact on
on individuals than just say if they
were a smaller thing and they
and they had their own ecosystem and you
know they weren't really
capable of existing at the scale that
could push other people
out and say hey if you're not on ios
your product isn't going to survive
that's a concern now for applications
you know
um you can't just be on android like
it's it's not possible
um so i think given that the scale of
their
enterprise has reached that level
you know there's definitely it changes
the conversation i think than if it was
just another player
in a in a sea of of you know possible
distribution platforms
yeah i think if you mean if you could if
you could use a different store
on that on your iphone an apple could
try i'd say apple charge whatever
percentage they want to
but you can't use a different store on
your phone yeah you know it's like yeah
on
steam takes i don't know what it's like
20 30 i think it's
somewhere around there you can use yeah
you can use good old games
you can use epic you can use other game
launchers you don't have to use steam so
they can charge whatever they want
but when you like if that's the only one
you can use and you aren't allowed to
use any others it starts to get
real dicey yeah and it's like i i have a
problem with that
but also to your second question about
should you be allowed to install apps
from third-party
stuff it's like i feel like that is a
little bit more complicated because then
that opens the door to
to you know viruses and stuff like that
every i like the fact that i cannot
install anything on my iphone that i
can't get through the store so that way
i know every single app that's on my
phone has already been vetted
and they probably say you can install
whatever you want your iphone you just
have to remove ios yeah
or or jailbreaking you know that's the
actual other option that i have done
before and it works and then you
actually do have access to all these
other tools you can basically emulate
android tell me that's not against their
terms of service though
uh i don't know probably
i don't know how well they can police it
i guess that's what i where my head was
going it's like
you you probably can't update your phone
anymore but you know whatever it still
works
you i mean i don't yeah do you know
those following apps that you could
download and see
like who's unfollowing you and all that
i've never yeah so you can download an
app and it literally puts all of your
instagram stuff in there and it can show
you
how many people unfollowed you who
unfollowed you who has you blocked all
of that right i had a friend who just
downloaded one of those apps
and it immediately hacked her instagram
and took it over
okay so that's slightly different that's
like within this whole
uh operating system she probably gave it
her username and password didn't she
yeah
yeah oh yeah she immediately freaked out
because like when you when you agree to
like they actually tell you all right
this is what we're gonna have access to
and you have to literally hit okay
and so that's why it frustrates me
sometimes whenever i'm trying to like
i i forget what but like say
allow youtube to be signed in on my my
tv or something like that and it's like
we want to be able to
look at all of your video search history
and we want to be able to post things on
your behalf and i'm like no i don't want
to do that there's like
no youtube on your tv yeah and this that
is the actual answer but
it's just the way it's phrased that way
they need that sort of access to be able
to activate like one small feature
the youtube on a tv thing is a bad
example but it's honestly
kind of a crappy system it's either get
more specific with your wording
or you know hold developers accountable
if you are policing your platform
to not be able to just be like i'm lazy
i'm just going to have every single
check box come up full access to all
your stuff and rude access to drive it's
cool just
yeah i don't have to bother tick tock
yeah the amount of access we just give
away for free is oh yeah
creepy it's actually like the jargon
that's like popping up i'm like
okay take my 99 cents
yeah so here's another uh google product
that was killed niko
tilt brush oh that's right yeah wtf
google
but okay i do think tilt brushes
you know it's not like they just removed
it from the internet entirely i do think
you can still get access to tilt brush
i'm not exactly sure how
they gave it to somebody or open source
maybe yeah maybe it's free now
so actually maybe it's better it was
always free but it was 20 bucks
no i'm pretty sure it was always free i
remember not getting it because i didn't
want to pay 20 bucks for it
well then it was shortly free thereafter
when nobody bought it maybe it's free
now that google's killed it
also google cardboard yeah well there
you have it
well that was kind of a that was kind of
a gag to begin with
i mean kind of youtube messages never
like fully serious but
oh they killed youtube for nintendo 3ds
here's one here's one did you guys ever
use this one
dodgeball no dodgeball was a
location-based
social network where users texted their
location to the service and it notified
them
of friends and points of interest nearby
scary i think i remember this one
snapchat did that here's one that we all
actively used
hangouts that's right yeah we just
killed that like two months ago really
hangouts google hangouts are not dead
it's weird because
what google i feel like they're trying
to do is they're trying to come up with
their imessage and their face time like
what's our one brand name
like messaging platform what's our one
brand name video platform
currently they're like uh hangouts wait
no damn it
uh duo god dang it
voice the messages
messages youtube messages yeah imagine
imagine for a moment here
if we change our channel name every year
because we couldn't decide whether that
was a good one
it's like no or we have we have eight
channels
that all make the same content just
slightly differently
oh that's another one google jump this
is one that
most of you are probably going to be
unfamiliar with but they basically
developed this really intense
crazy system that converted a an array
of
gopros into a single 360 image that was
3d
no matter where you looked wow and that
is pretty crazy because i got really
into trying to make like
360 3d uh video over the last
multiple times over the last several
years and you would you'd
you can make 3d video by having two
different lenses pointing straight
forward
okay put a couple gopros together 3d
video it's great
and people what people started trying to
do is they would put little pairs
of gopros looking this way pair gopros
looking this way and then basically
stitch it all together to make a 360
image
but it was never quite good you'd be
like alright it's pretty good this way
it's pretty good that way but in between
the two ways your eyes are like kind of
cross-eyed and it's weird
so we used we used google jump sorry we
did yes we did
so basically imagine instead of having
all these pairs that are looking in a
general
in a specific parallel direction every
single camera in a ring
is pointed directly outwards from the
center of that ring
so you have all these cameras that are
basically going pointed this way that
way that way you know like hands of a
clock
and what google did was they basically
would take
i think it was like 32 cameras you would
literally plug in the sd cards from all
32 cameras
offload all the footage onto the google
servers they would process it for like
two straight days and then send you a
download link
where you'd have the left and right eye
perfectly set so that no matter which
direction you looked
it was always perfectly 3d in that
direction
it was crazy they brought over a 3d
printed
gopro rig that was a that was about i
don't know maybe 18 inches
yeah a little smaller it was like a
medium pizza yeah
and uh this thing yeah you had you had
each individual gopro faced
vertically directly outwards pointing
directly
yeah in an array and then all their
cables running into the center
yeah no and it's actually a genius idea
because what they're doing is they're
basically pulling
slices from each lens each camera
for a specific view so imagine you have
this camera pointed that way
and then this camera pointed this way
but you're trying to look at this one
piece over here so this camera
you know even though they're all pointed
outwards you can still get a 3d image
from it by pulling this slice that's
pointed that way and this slice that's
pointed parallel so like this camera
over here is looking that way
and then that camera over there is also
pointing that way i mean is that kind of
like basically
synthesize a brand new image from all of
those slices
yeah it was really really cool thing and
no one else has come close to doing it
and no one else
can do it now um isn't that like uh
basically a
video version of a photo scan
effectively
no no it was a a photo scan is a little
bit is a very different process that
involves like
actual 3d geometry and whatnot uh
i think sounds like a jank insta360
honestly
yeah you gotta see it to get it yeah i
mean i don't know part of it is that i
think
360 video is
overrated if you're trying to consume it
the way it's meant to be consumed i love
360 cameras insta360 is an incredible
company in my opinion
i love their cameras but i rarely
actually use what they give me
uh rather i rarely use what the cameras
give me for like oh
360 video you can look anywhere i can
look behind me
like no one actually really wants to sit
in a chair and like oh wow look
i'm i can see video behind me with a vr
headset
but 3d on the other hand i do think is
critical to the future of media
because that depth information is a big
deal
um we see it in video games and vr we
don't see it in in
video typically unless you're at a 3d
movie which
no one seems to really want to do making
3d um
like what is that like in times square
headboard uh billboards oh yeah no okay
so i know what you're talking about
that's not technically 3d that's a
perspective trick
where they're like all right people are
probably going to be looking at this
billboard from about this spot or so
so we're going to render it out as if
we're viewing it from this spot and
we're going to play with the space a
little bit
and it's an awesome illusion that
actually works it looks pretty
cool like it was like a hand coming out
and there was one that had a car
crashing and then yes coming out but it
was definitely like okay i have to be
facing the car
this way yeah i do really like that
that's a little bit of like projection
mapping kind of
i got another one this is a big one
ladies and gentlemen
youtube gaming all right i remember
going to like the youtube gaming show
after e3 i have some youtube gaming
socks actually
youtube gaming lasted less time than my
socks i still have the socks i don't
have any holes in them
and i wear them about once a month
there's a youtube gaming
uh coaster i believe in that room that
you guys are in
yeah it's right by a christian i believe
wait really yeah i remember over here
right
upstairs in the other office nevermind
yeah because google gaming that was when
sorry youtube gaming that was when they
were trying to compete with twitch right
yeah
and now it's just you can still stream
on youtube but there's less of a
marketed approach to it for gaming
yeah yeah remember specifically designed
as a competitor to twitch
yeah because of course they needed if
somebody else has been successful they
need to get in there and shove their way
right right every other giant 800 pound
gorilla body
into a tiny room i mean but all of the
big guys
i know but like i don't like it
i i wish the people at these companies
would apply a little bit of like
should we to their questions of can we's
well have you ever
watched silicon valley of course i love
that show
yeah i mean the guy the guy that plays
the head of google
is the epitome that they epitomize that
in his role
it's it's a concept he's constantly just
yeah belson
no ho-ho gavin governor
i'm sure
so that's that's his character in a
nutshell there's another
like aspect of kill google things that i
i see happening a little by little that
makes me pretty wary and
they've killed a lot of things that made
their search engine a better search
engine
but made it so they were less able to
control you
because the better the search engine
gets the less they can direct your
searches to the people that paid money
for ads or the sites they want you to
see so they used to have the ability to
search
forums to search discussions and in a
internet there's like 99 [ __ ] and
bots
and copy pasted articles like i don't
know if you've ever tried to learn a
really obscure
3d technique or like if you have a
really strange bug in your 3d
programming you're trying to search for
a very specifically like
phrased or worded thing in it like
the first results that come up are
usually the most generalized
basic ass like oh like blender donut
tutorial and i'm searching like how do i
take these nerves and turn convert them
to like four sided polygons you know
it's like
you do you got something really
technical and it gives you like the like
layman's approach
uh you know for results so like you know
here's a times article about how 3d was
using marvel movies like
which is made for like general audiences
when they're just killing time and
trying to like read away you know some
minutes of the day on the internet
but in terms like actually being a tool
for knowledge it stops being that
and the thing is like these days you get
so much
crap that's just people constantly
copying and pasting articles to put on
news sites because of the way how google
indexes pages
they need to be updated they need to be
current so people literally just content
farm or they're just going to grab an
old article from someone else copy it
paste it change some more just call it a
day
which means that your information is
constantly degrading like it's a lossy
codec you know filming a video over and
over
off of a screen your information is
constantly degrading and none of its new
information it's just the same
information being repeated
and so in order to get away from all
that and like actually get some real
discussions some real words written by
real people
i would always just search the google
discussions search because then you'd
actually get somebody's
like giving like an honest review of a
product like hey this is the thing i
have i bought this
bike here's what i like about it here's
what i don't like about it versus some
bs
advertiser written pr release that's you
know been pasted on a thousand websites
and of course they killed it it's like a
reddit echo
anything any discussion they let you
search well you could use other search
engines right
no one else had a discussion search like
that um it's actually
fully done you can't monetize that you
can't monetize it that's right
something that's actually it can't be
useful is it you can't google it
you know they also killed right away
because they're encrypted search
yeah like hey here's an ability to
search something tracked oops i'll get
rid of that
that's dead yeah we can't sell that back
to advertisers
so uh can we just get rid of that
oh i didn't even realize it killed uh
the google url shortener
yeah that's another there's another one
like let's go and let's bully
you know bitly let's steal about your
user base their company
url shortener hype phase and then we'll
kill ours
thereby you know the google url
shortener was almost 10 years old
it's super useful why kill it just let
it sit and let it be
they sold it no no like killed it
killed it oh yeah youtube annotations
yeah yeah to be fair they were still
figuring out youtube at the time
uh yeah we use an app for our security
cameras here
called nest so it's concerning to see
that they killed that
eight months ago oh jordan can you
explain can you explain the process of
that service now to everybody how it
works
well because you can't you can't uh
you can't talk to anybody right so we
yeah amazing so we have our security
cameras and we also have the way to get
into the door
and now the the software still works
perfectly fine
like i can go in and still add and take
away
numbers and people coming in but there's
no there's no phone number
there's no one to talk to there's no
customer service
all i can find is like reddit
conversations of like yeah
they're gone they're out like i don't
know where they went so
i mean we're still like we're still
rocking with them
i don't know how long but then that's
completely separate that's wink that's a
whole nother one so now that's
right okay yeah that's for the doors and
then we have
security cameras that google killed
eight months ago so i guess
there's no one to call for that either
wait google nest yeah google nest is
dead
yeah yeah it said about eight months ago
wait three barely even started wait
though that i thought yeah i said it was
three years old
and then they killed secure killed eight
months ago nest secure was a security
kiss
system with a an alarm keypad and
monitor sensor with a
microphone google nest secure yeah okay
that's different than google nest
works with nest api i believe there is
google i think nest is still a thing
necessary
google now secure is dead oh so but you
know every time i log in
it wants me to make a new thing through
once you make a google plus again so
that
so i think it gets connected somehow
because every time i'm like not now
and i think panoramio is dead panoramic
was my go-to for matte paintings
or i just like panoramic was basically
you go to a map it was also it used to
be also
google maps had image search on the map
where uh any geotagged images you could
search them oh cool which was super
useful they killed it i don't know why
uh probably because it's too effective
at getting you what you wanted and once
again they couldn't direct you towards
where they wanted you to go
um so panoramio was basically high
quality like nature photos or basically
like
photos taking on locations to take with
gps someone had a google map
search except they were like all high
quality photos like you know
really crisp 1080p plus so like if you
want a picture of mountains for your map
painting you just go to a spot in like
switzerland
pull up panoramio and see what pictures
have been tagged and then you can find
some great mountain pictures
um oh my god i got a good one yeah what
is it
chromecast audio oh yeah you guys may
have never heard of this but basically
it's a it's a hardware
that plugs into basically any
um audio box that will
connect to it and then you connect to
the chromecast audio
piece of hardware like via bluetooth and
you can play anything
into that uh speaker system
without like any sort of additional
applications or bluetooth or anything
yeah i think they probably realized uh
that
that hardware was probably going to go
extinct very shortly
and they're like yeah this is the lost
cause but then there's still just
regular chromecast oh yeah i know
chromecast itself is still
yeah i've used the chromecast for years
that works so
well with the lg tvs mm-hmm yeah do you
guys remember all those chromebook
uh ads we did yeah and those
those no longer exist either wait from
the pixelbug
the chromebooks don't exist chromebook
pixels are dead they don't make them
there are certain pixels that still
exist i think
the chromebooks yeah but i think the
chromebook pixels
are done so like what you you what are
your googles what i have is
i have a chromebook pixel upstairs um
huh
yeah imagine paying a thousand dollars
for a computer then two years later the
company just like
we're done we're uh yeah we're done here
i was hoping this was the hardware would
last longer than two years but you guys
apparently just uh are done
so okay another thing i used to use was
google news and weather
and and and uh they had google play
newsstand
as well they got rid of all that and
brought it into google news
um so i do like google news though
efficiency thing but
yeah yeah consolidation perhaps how
about gmail uh google mail inbox
remember i have g i didn't i don't
remember i don't even know what that is
well so
i've been using gmail for like 10 years
right yeah longer than that now
and google for a while has this thing
like let's rearrange the ui it's like
please stop
me and millions of other people are
doing just fine
with how it is i don't like change well
at a certain point when it's something
as simple as email no i i remember you
don't need to rearrange those five
buttons to be in different spots that
doesn't help me
um yeah so they came up with google
inbox which is them trying to be like
okay we're gonna try to make it fancier
so that like
you know it's organized a little bit
differently and then like messages that
we think are more important are gonna be
organized to be on top and like
you know things we highlighted it's like
yeah so you're getting rid of just a
simple chronological organization
like yeah we're gonna have it be all
smart and algorithmic it's like no
thanks yeah
no thanks just i need my emails to be in
chronological order thank you very much
seriously though yeah okay maps
or google maps or google maps google
maps yeah
yeah everyone has google maps here oh
yeah 100 percent
google maps almost made me quit then
when they started uh they started
bugging me about once a week to add my
contacts to google maps i was like if
this happens
more than like two or three more weeks i
will uninstall google maps and never use
it again
google maps was asking you to add
contacts yeah
i i hate the idea that somebody else who
i'm sure has me in their contacts list
has added me
like has uploaded their contacts or
something so it's like you know every
company gets my phone number now with my
name paired because some other person
i was like whatever then they share
their contacts with
you know google facebook never asked me
to add uh contacts
probably because you're already sharing
them because you're on an android phone
how dare you nico
i mean that's actually true i dare like
legit though i'm gonna check right now
there's no way
your your contacts are a hundred percent
shared on google maps you had an android
phone
it's built into the system how dare you
i've never really
so apple maps is what you're you're
comparing google i use
good old apple maps
uh i mean i might in the near future
they made a big huge improvement to it
with the most recent wwbc
nico did not allowed location
denied camera contacts microphone
storage
what's up
[Laughter]
all right you got me through google maps
but also all of the other google
services you use
every single one of them has those
options too so one of them might have
another one name another one google
settings
settings what do you mean settings i
don't know i'm making it up
my point is that like he's looking
forward google's like
fingers are so deep in the past because
every i deny
i deny denied i do too i i always like
try to not deny when i can um
you can ah so many things
it's really kind of too bad like you
don't find success if you give up one or
two years into it
it's not even enough time to go to
college and get a degree you know
an associate that's about it i think
what's the saying is like most buildings
fail eighty percent of buildings fail
two years in the
uh eighty percent of the rest of them
fail five years in yeah but what's that
what's that other uh what's that other
phrase though where it's like
early bird gets a worm no no it's not a
phrase
like the sunk cost fallacy i think oh
right where it's like oh we put in this
much time we should just at least see it
through the
sun it's like fallacy yeah but if you
actually take a step back and actually
really kind of
try to you know understand whether or
not this is working where it's going
and if you conclude that it's not going
to go anywhere
there's no reason to continue true but i
think here's the problem with applying a
sunk cost fallacy to this is let's say
let's say you're on top of a cliff and
there's somebody at the bottom of the
cliff you're like i need to figure out a
way to get you up here
like throw it on the rope i'm like okay
you turn on the rope and like you're
holding on to it and they're climbing up
the cliff
but they're halfway after like it's too
slow sunk cost fallacy
and you let go of the rope but people
are still holding on to it
like that's that's what's happening with
a lot of this stuff is like they want
to launch a product and have thousands
of people using it
and then to kill it two years into those
people using it
who have paid you money with an
understanding like that's starting today
is google money ask all those pro stadia
subscribers
pro stations are they killing them and
then just using like the same
patents to go make another no they're
just done so they're just
patents are done no they're not selling
the patents they might they might
they must be making it's more about the
the tools the software the things
they've made
a little less about the patents and more
about just putting there's also a demand
for all the developers and coders and
engineers behind the scenes they're like
we need you guys for something
actually useful that's probably not a
consideration that we've made
at this point so that's that's a
significant consideration i think
i do think each product is you know if
they have a team of developers behind
them those products are burning cash
yeah right just if you do actually go
through with launching a product that
people have paid money for
you need to put in more time than you
initially
want to to support those people that
have been your customers and paid for
this product or service that you've
promised like you just
you can't just stop the moment you stop
making profit when people have
had an exchange with you you know like
if we have a business
arrangement or a contract and the moment
the moment i'm like oh this is tough
like i can't just walk away right then
you know which is what
you know i'm sure it's not that simple
for these products but in a way it also
is
because it's google i mean they do have
lots of resources they do have money
some of these things like
for example custom google maps i had
years worth of boundary waters trips
i've done drawn on these maps
so i go back and revisit them and we
have like you know little things marked
and they just killed it
i was like nico you're you you're not
part of a company that's
trading uh 1 641 billion market
cap at two thousand dollars a share
wait one thousand you mean trillion
there's truly one
one point six trillion oh oh one
thousand billion gotcha gotcha yeah yeah
yeah you know it's like anything cost
money what are you gonna do just have a
trillion dollars
here's what here's one along the lines
of our 800 pound gorilla
theory neighborly neighborly was a
mobile app designed to help you learn
about your neighborhood by asking other
residents
uh find out about local services and
facilities in your area from people who
live around you does that sound like
anything else
facebook next door yeah yeah
there's a little like let's show us
elbow our way in we'll call it
neighborly
imagine so what sorry go on imagine
you're you're standing there on the
nice bend of a beautiful river you take
out your canvas
you start painting this really great
picture of this landscape
and somebody else comes in like hi i'm
gonna paint here too i like your spot
and they sit up right next to you and
start painting like whoa
and they kind of push you out of the way
and they're kind of in front of you and
they're in your field of view it's like
oh
cool here's another one google tv
tv was the smart tv platform that
integrated android and chrome
i remember that active television
overlay freddie had a google tv back in
the day
it was actually really nice and then i
guess they just decided that being
the front leading men on earth being the
front
people on like a brand new technology is
like that's too hard we want to copy
other people
not come up with it ourselves what was
the idea behind it what would you do
it was smart tv it was a smart tv before
smart tv sort of thing it was great it
worked wonderfully you could pull up
youtube on it and like search stuff it
was really cool it's before youtube was
actually on your tv
and then they're just like oh we're just
gonna let everybody catch up to us and
stop doing that so what's the deal
the logistics of television just
manufacturing is
not we're not gonna do that yeah i mean
that makes sense to me that's yeah but
like stadia like uh
the streaming video game platform
everyone purchased it
you could buy the controller it came
with the subscription
but you didn't come with the games you
still had to buy the games
that which died like they cancelled that
it ended up going under but then
i also hear that they're still focusing
on it behind the scenes it's still
actually alive and well
is still around i would definitely not
say it's alive and well
it is still around yep it's like
moviepass in the last
couple of months so i was like no
everything's good please don't try to
use it
dude i bought a year nothing to see here
i bought a year's subscription to
moviepass or a year's access i guess it
was like 10 bucks a month so i just paid
120 bucks i was like all right all i got
to do is go see at least 10 movies
and i will have made my money back and i
did i watched 10 movies over the course
of a few months and then
i ended up not really i ended up i don't
know i
i didn't go for like eight months and it
canceled at the end of it so it didn't
like auto renew which would have killed
me but
yeah and then ever since then it just
like yeah moviepass just their offerings
started getting worse and worse yeah you
couldn't go at certain times couldn't go
to certain theaters
it was that was because amc was like
they got their own pass
moviepass is really just a precursor to
the streaming platforms that we see now
in a way it's like
i'm not i don't really want to pay 15
bucks a ticket to go to the theater and
watch
a disney movie i would rather pay 15
bucks a month for disney plus
you know and get the movies when they
come out at disney plus and you can
still do the theater thing like that's
great but like
i feel like a company would also find it
more valuable to have somebody subscribe
for 15
a month because do you really go see a
movie once a month it's like no
and of the fifteen dollars you spend how
much that actually goes to the studio i
suppose i mean it really depends on the
person definitely used to
all you dads are not going to be going
to the movie theaters once a month
unless you're the kind of dad who needs
to be able to get out of the house with
your wife on a date night at least once
a month
i do feel like going to the movies honey
i do feel like everybody that bought a
moviepass actually used it enough to
make up for the cost of the movie pass
which is what killed them
yeah no they were banking on everyone
not doing that because here here's a pro
tip for all you ceos out there
if your business plan to your road to
profit is you banking on people not
using your product
uh you might have a flaw in your
business it's called a short sale niko
it's a movie pass people subscribe
they'll use it for a month and they'll
stop and then we'll just keep making
money once a month and they keep
subscribing because
they're not using it it's like what if
people use it it's like no yeah
how do you feel about it how do you feel
about like say disney charging like 30
bucks for a new movie that just drops
instantly
i think that's goofy it's weird right
it's like people buy it
and then and it's like all right again
it's the competition thing they put up
the money
sure i mean you could charge what you
want people are obviously paying for it
but i just can't imagine
it's a road to piracy and disney's
playing uh playing with fire if they
keep doing that
i mean yeah but it's also an
accessibility that was whole that was a
gabe newell's
whole thing from steam or rather valve
is that like piracy is just a
supply problem you know it's like if you
can get the supply people don't care
about the cost
i mean cost is part of the supply but
like if people for free
can do a better job of distributing your
thing digitally than you can
like then you're going to lose to piracy
like that was the problem back in the
day if
like there was no reason that these
companies couldn't have streaming
platforms for their movies outside of
their convoluted
you know licensing things with tv
sometimes but
beyond that like if literally a kid in
scandinavia can rip your file and get up
on a torrent and make it accessible for
anybody in the world to download the
next day
and you're not doing that as a company
you are underserving your customers
yeah but torrenting stuff is a little
harder than the average
joe is ready to do i don't know about
that
i don't know about that it's pretty easy
yeah
i mean yeah again we're on a we're a
futurism podcast here so obviously
everyone listening can handle doing that
sort of thing
but think about how stupid most people
are period
like they're not going to be able to
torrent anything being able to like they
can barely get disney plus on their tv
they're not going to be pirating stuff
they're going to be like oh i guess
i got to pay my 30 bucks for mulan
uh the other day it was like it was some
indian politician and he was like
talking to the i don't know if he was
actually saying these words or somebody
dubbed it with texts but he's like
democracy is basically government
by the people for the people the only
problem is
people are stupid
that's human human kind in a nutshell
okay here's a here's another one
here's another one google clips
i actually don't know google clips i'm
going to guess it's a video thing
yeah editing google eclipse was a
clip-on camera
that could automatically capture
interesting or relevant video clips
determined by machine learning
i do remember that actually it sounds
kind of interesting
oh they're cool they killed the measure
app for android that's cool
which is a great tool on the iphone i
love it yeah but i wouldn't be surprised
if apple kills it too
actually no apple's pretty good about
supporting things long beyond their
usefulness as long as they get their 30.
yeah i mean yeah
i like the devil needs his flesh
my only qualm against apple is the
thirty percent on the app store i think
and that
now's the time for them to change that
cause when like epic showed up and it's
weird that people are like so
anti-epic games like considering that
steam really could use some competition
and it's good for everyone yeah
like the most epic showed up steam
lowered their uh
their cut yeah their epics like we do we
don't need to take 30 percent
like we really technically don't need a
lot of this money we're making plenty of
money on fortnite so we'll take 10
or 15 percent and that seems like uh 20
is what we'll take not 30.
like wonderful awesome like there's
there's no way for that to happen on
ios which apple has made sure i think it
comes down to brand loyalty and how
stubborn people are about it you know
it's like and it's not even that
they they specifically really like this
brand it's that they're stubborn
and it's all they they know it's all
they've used i've only ever used steam
i've never used this new thing i don't
want this new thing it's the worst thing
it's like it just kind of raises up so
quickly no new things
no news as opposed to like taking a step
back and
understanding oh this competition is
good for everyone even if i don't ever
use it i'm glad it exists
because it makes the platform that i do
want to use you have to kind of step up
the game
it's the main reason why i hate that
there's no one-wheel competition
yeah you know like future motion needs a
competitor so that
everyone succeeds but they're living out
that they live in that 14-year uh patent
yeah they're they're riding that patent
wave rodnet
don't get me wrong i love me some future
motion but i would love me another one
i would love me a better onewheel yeah
look
our loyalty is fickle
uh here's one i bet they wish they
didn't get rid of google flew trends
okay this this one allowed you to
interesting uh google flu trends was a
service attempting to make accurate
predictions about flu activity
um yeah they should bring that back that
would have been
uh pretty useful about uh 18 months ago
yeah they they canned that along with
the whole uh pandemic preparedness group
at the government so you know
it's like i've never used my seat belt
why would i even
it's never like i've never had to use my
airbags why are they put them in my car
i've never been in a car accident so why
do i need airbags this is stupid
like i'm good enough to not need seat
belts it's like oh yeah race car drivers
don't wear seat belts
right that's how it works that's that
yeah that's how it works they don't have
any five
straps covering their body yeah that's
not a seat belt yeah that's a that's a
harness
race car drivers do not use seat belts
that's true
google reader hey what does that one
sound like
it sounds like a kindle maybe google
wait
i thought it was a competitor to a pdf
reader
oh no it was an rss atom feed
aggregator operated by google remember
whatever it was all about rss feeds
yeah i never used rss near the die
because it just seems like
you mean just a conglomeration of blog
posts
well funny enough that's that's how we
distribute this podcast when it's not on
youtube is
the rss feed must be a thing where like
you know
the technology is how you just that's
how you distribute all podcasts still
is even if you're using a service you
still need that that service will create
an rss feed for you
so it ended up being more of a
behind-the-scenes infrastructure thing
than like a customer facing
yeah yeah it's very much an
infrastructural thing
youtube video editor was killed yep
wow that's weird so it's like on one
hand tiktok goes ahead and makes editing
videos really accessible and easy and
as a platform blow up because people can
make more content yeah
and then uh youtube's like no
so i mean what if we didn't
part me really wants to talk about tick
tock right now do it
i have five minutes
really wants to not talk about tick tock
no talk about tick tock i would love to
talk about two well no okay
so it's like i i've been using tick tock
a little bit over the last couple months
uh not as much as jenna
she's gotten really into it and and i
think everyone who uses it kind of
understands the the black hole nature of
tick-tock it's like you get sucked in
and it's like wow this is actually a
pretty good video and then like you go
to the next one wow this is
also actually a surprisingly good video
and i might end up rehashing some of our
conversation we had literally yesterday
but uh the way i see it is that
tiktok is more than just like a social
media platform they actually
nailed making a really good video editor
because on your phone yeah they made
being able to simply just edit a bunch
of clips together
add sound add music add little extra
pieces to it be creative with it
they made the act of doing that really
really
easy they have a green screen feature
yeah and so because of that
you have all of these people who maybe
would never have or sorry you have all
of these very creative people who maybe
lacked the technical uh knowledge or
skill set to be able to use like an
editing program on a computer or even
have access to a computer
potentially these are all people now
that are like oh i have
i'm actually a really clever person i'm
actually a really funny person
and they're able to now make really
funny and creative videos
just using their phone and tiktok
is an editing program that has allowed
that to happen
you know and that's something that i've
never really ever tried you
doing before in my life it's like
anytime i want to put up a video i'll
you know open up my editing program
maybe even an effects software like
throw something together
and upload it uh to these words i think
it's blowing up so
largely globally so that's one part of
it
one part of it is the fact that now
we're seeing uh
excellent content now you know
all of these people like the the cream
of the crop is really rising up
and so you're actually getting on the
one hand really really good content out
there
uh more so than i think uh any of us
here have really realized
and secondly i think their algorithm is
just so scary good at identifying who
you are and what your interests are
which goes back to perhaps some
problematic uh morals
but uh you know
it's it's yeah that's what you have to
say about that is i mean i'm just saying
it's like
they figure you out and at the end of
the day it's like you're you continue to
look at it and the more you look the
more they know who you are
uh yeah so it's good for humanity
that's a question i don't think i'm
capable of answering
have you guys watched the new bo burnham
uh i started watching it but my wife
wanted to stop watching it so we stopped
watching it
nice oh she was too busy watching one of
the most amazing
creations we got we got like 15 20
minutes in i was enjoying it i think
it's pretty good
but it just wasn't the vibe for a night
no fair enough fair enough the movie is
awesome
she was watching tick tock videos wasn't
she that's why she didn't want to watch
it
maybe
um in all honesty uh everyone should
definitely check it out
it's great one dude by himself
films and shoots and acts and does it
all honestly i love bo burnham he is an
incredible individual
he is also an og youtuber um started up
on youtube
you know 12 13 years ago
uh yeah you know there's there's there's
a crew of like a dozen creators from
like the
late 2000s 2008 era who
lonely island is kind of in that realm i
mean kinda lonely island
snl well before snl they were uh channel
okay sure but the idea of like you know
okay you're a funny person you're a
creative person but no one is helping
you you gotta
you know do it yourself and youtube was
amazing for that youtube literally
created a bit of a cultural revolution
in that regard
and you know we kind of don't really see
as much of that these days it's so
huge there's so much noise um you know
there's so much corporate money
uh all over the place it's kind of hard
to tell what is or isn't
a single person doing it all but bo
burnham is a single guy
and i i it really shines through in his
special
the fact that it's just him doing all of
it yeah it's pretty amazing stuff
and like from what i've seen yeah the
way i mean
it's really funny it's really
entertaining it's insightful in many
ways
it's it's exactly
mike my buddy mike put it really well
right he thinks it's the the best
creation to have come out of the the
pandemic in terms of like the art and
the
media that was created during the
pandemic like that's the one that like
captures that moment uh in a really
i guess poignant way poignant yeah
yeah yeah obernam's inside on netflix go
check it out
okay yeah i want to finish it i do want
to finish it
here's a song about the internet it's uh
can i interest you in a little bit of
everything all the time
that's just like heroin you know and
just like
it's mainlined into and like it started
with you know kids
like two years old they get good at
using an ipad and like now they're like
eight
nine ten eleven years old and tick
tock's a thing it's like
it's just that it's like main lighted
into my arteries baby
yeah i mean you guys have that sort of
like internal debate where you're like
i want my kid to not have that sort of
mental highway to this stuff but also i
don't want them to be
non-competitive later in life i think
there's a pretty big difference between
letting your kid click on thumbnails on
youtube until they get tired of clicking
on thumbnails
and say you know understanding other
human experiences aside from their own
and how to use computers
i hear you yeah like we don't we don't
let milo have
we don't let her hold the phone and we
only play
currently we only play uh music videos
by the okie dokie brothers
where they sing about like dogs and
horses and like abc
songs from only like sesame street or
abc mouse
okay those are the only things we play
for her she gets
she gets like 25 to 30 minutes a day at
most it's like screen time
and beyond like and we're always in
control of it because we did for a
moment like you know she would just
watch video on the phone but then
it's like oh i swipe up there's
thumbnails there's pictures i click the
one a new video
that one had a video 18 months they
figured yeah
and that's where it's like can't let her
just go through it of course in the ads
start playing and like now my like
you know two-year-old daughter is seeing
ads and stuff like that like i don't
want you that you can maybe try
something where it's like
you can put on uh some i don't know i
feel like you can maybe connect a phone
to a second display that's not a touch
screen perhaps
we do that okay we just cast it to our
tv for example
okay but uh the you know the thing is
like and this is something people talk
about like
well when you're raising a kid it's
important for a kid to be able to
understand how to deal with pain
because you're going to have pain in
your life you know and it starts with a
kid learning how to calm themselves down
once they are crying
because that's not a thing that you can
just do like you're crying and you're
just crying crying crying
it's like you need to learn how to take
control of that chill out
take a breath and get over that natural
reflex right
okay uh same thing like you need to
learn how to fall asleep you need to
learn how to do these things that are
important things to learn in life and
you only learn how to calm yourself down
if no one else calms you down if every
time you get upset someone else calms
you down
then you are not equipped with the tools
to handle that likewise with pain
if the first time you're feeling pain is
when you're 25 years old
you're gonna have a really tough time
dealing with it you know
it's like you need to you need to learn
that when you trip it hurts you need to
learn that when you do something goofy
sometimes you cross the line and you
fall over and you hurt yourself like
i got that lesson down yeah and when you
do hurt yourself you need to learn how
to deal with it and
it's not just pain in terms of like i
stubbed my toe but there's emotional
pains there's frustrations there's
oh my hand's stuck there's i can't
figure this out like we have all these
different types of pains in our life
and you when you're raising a child they
need to experience those pains
and then they need to be learned how to
deal with and handle those pains on
their own
so one of the pains that we all
encounter is boredom and if you
are conditioned to never have to
experience that pain
then you freak out when you get bored
and you don't have access to the thing
you know your morphine drip of the
internet and through boredom
comes things like inspiration thought
reflection quiet solitude zen meditation
like yeah you sleep like you need to
have boredom you need to be comfortable
with it you need to know how to deal
with it
and turn inwards for example or find
something else to do or motivate
yourself to do something else
and you can kill all those muscles if
every time you're bored you immediately
pull out your phone
and especially if you're two years old
when it happens so yeah i find myself
doing that
like even if you just say waiting
outside your friend's apartment to open
up the gate and you just
whip it out and you have literally
nothing to do you're just scrolling or
you see someone coming down the street
and you pull out your phones you don't
have to make eye contact
how many times notice how many times
you're in public and
you're like in a waiting area or you're
around
you you're around a stranger i i
over the last few years i've just i've
noticed that so significantly because
the
the first thing that most people do not
everybody does it but
first thing people do is they pull out
their phone it's like i mean same for me
like
the moment i have to wait my phone
appears out of nowhere
same same yeah and now you don't talk to
each other you don't
you know i've definitely made it a habit
when i'm walking around glendale i keep
my phone
in my pocket and i will purposely go
like hi how are you even if they don't
look at me because we were like
human contact like when i grew up i grew
up like right on the cusp of like
you talk to people you play outside and
then like bam the internet came
and then i have to even learn about the
internet but i miss it
i i watch it so many times i'm i'm
driving and i see someone just waiting
and they just pull out their phone and
they're just
you just even swiping through their apps
and i'm like there's this whole world
that you could be looking at when i was
connecting we would go on these
road trips every summer my dad would
bank all of his years vacation
and we would spend it all over like two
or three weeks uh and later on when he
got more vacation we would take an
entire month off and we'd go on these
long
road trips from like louisiana where i
was living
up to say like the tip of maine or up to
the tip of washington we'd take an
entire month
just camping every night and just
driving the whole way and so my sister
and i spent so much time
sitting in the back of a truck doing
nothing nothing oh my god we
we play we played our tamagotchi to the
point that they broke
and that was that was a treat because
the year prior we didn't have anything
and then like i think the year after
that we finally got like game boys and
that was that was a big deal but like
you know a game boy isn't going to last
you a full days of driving in the back
you still spend a significant amount of
time just sitting there
staring out the window looking at i
ended up coming up with like an
imaginary friend a little bit
who was the cornfields whenever you're
driving by a corn field if you look at
them
they have like these little legs that
are running by yeah and he was my friend
you would have never made that friend if
you had yeah tick-tock
maybe not corn fields but definitely
like sugar cane fields or any sort of
like you know
rows of fields yeah your imagination
definitely does
just keep going you're in your thoughts
rather than in a screen
yeah that was actually when i started
doing my earliest consideration of
parallax
i really started thinking a lot about
parallax i didn't know what it was at
the time but i just remember thinking
like
why are the things in the distance
moving slower than the things in the
form same same i remember yeah
100 yeah
alas okay that's there you have it does
that mean deep at the end
that was great uh i'm down for these
philosophical questions remember
futurism futurology i don't know what
your term it is
leave a comment down below maybe we
already asked this question maybe
there's already a comment down below in
a previous video
we just didn't see it but i'd love to
hear people's thoughts on what we talk
about too i love reading the comments in
the podcast they're always like a little
deeper
a little like more thought out like you
know actual discussion it's really nice
i think this this podcast may have been
a little bit more on the depressing side
we're just talking about a bunch of dead
products
well i better play a d minor then
[Laughter]
full circle take us out jake
if you're driving through a cornfield
and you're thinking about parallax
[Music]
is it on your phone or is it in all the
mirrors
or is it out the windows i don't know
[Music]
and is this a futurology or a futurist
podcast let us know
and get them deep cuts in the comments
ladies and gentlemen because that's
where it's at thank you for
watching trouton's croutons and uh
we'll catch you guys here next week yeah
thanks for watching everyone
three two one